الصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
الدرس موصول
حول
استقبال
الكعبه ونسخ استقبال بيت المقدس في الصلاه
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى صرف وجهه
صرف وجهه وجهه صلاته صلى الله عليه وسلم
واماته
الى الكعبه
وذلك بعد ان كان
تقريبا
خمسه عشر عاما
وهو يصلي الى البيت المقدس فلما هاجر الى
المدينه
فانه
بعد هجرته لم يستطع ان
يواصل
استقبال الكعبه
وبيت المقدس معا
فكان يقلب وجهه في السماء
وهو يدعو الله سبحانه وتعالى بان يجعل
قبلته
قبله ابيه ابراهيم
فاستجاب الله سبحانه وتعالى له
ونسخ استقبال بيت المقدس في الصلاه
وجعل قبله العالمين
من امه محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم الكعبه
المشرفه
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله وكان يصلي الى
بيت المقدس وقال لجبريل
وددت ان الله صرف وجهي عن قبله اليهود
فقال انما انا عبد فادعو ربك واساله
فجعل يقلب وجهه في السماء يرجو ذلك
فانزل الله عليه قد نرى تقلب وجهك في
السماء الايه
وذلك بعد 16 شهرا من مقدمه المدينه قبل
بدر بشهرين وكان في ذلك
حكم عظيمه
ومحنه للمسلمين والمشركين واليهود
والمنافقين فاما المسلمون فقالوا امنا به
كل من عند ربنا
وهم الذين هدى الله ولم تكن كبيره عليهم
واما المشركون فقالوا كما رجع الى قبلتنا
يوشك ان يرجع الى ديننا وما رجع اليها الا
انها الحق
واما اليهود فقالوا خالف قبله الانبياء
قبله
واما المنافقون فقالوا ما يدري اين يتوجه
ان كانت الاولى حقا فقد تركها وان كانت
الثانيه هي الحق فقد كان على باطل
وكثرت اقاويل السفهاء من الناس
وكانت كما قال الله تعالى وانها لكبيره
الا على الذين هدى الله
وكانت محنه من الله ليرى من يتبع الرسول
ممن ينقلب على عقبيه
ولما كان شان القبله عظيما وطئ سبحانه
قبلها امر النسخ وقدرتي عليه وانه ياتي
بخير من المنسوخ او مثله ثم عقبه بالتوبيخ
لمن تعنت على رسوله ولم ينقض له
هو يذكر سوابق الايات من سوره البقره
الى ان وصل الله سبحانه وتعالى في درج
الكلام الى قوله قد نروا تقلب وجهك في
السماء فلا نولي انك قبله ترضاها فول
لوجهك شطر المسجد الحرام بهذه الكلمه
صرف
جهه الصلاه
صرفت جهه الصلاه من
بيت المقدس الى
القبله المعروفه الى الكعبه البيت الحرام
المسجد الحرام
وهذا امر
عظيم الا على الذين هدى الله يعني الامه
بشكل عام
من اعظم شعائر
دين الاسلام القبله القبله هي التي تجمع
المسلمين
وهي
القبله والجهه جهه الصلاه ما في ما فيها
خلاف ابدا بين العلماء كلهم يقول
بوجوب استقبال القبله وجعلوه شرطا وبعضهم
ركنا
في صحه الصلاه
فشان القبله شان عظيم
لكن الله سبحانه وتعالى قد ينسخ من اياته
ما شاء حتى وان كانت
القبله التي نتوجه اليها في صلاتنا
والله عز وجل وطى النسخ
النسخ يعني ايش يعني رفع حكم
بعد وضعه يعني الله عز وجل ينزل حكما
ينزل فردا فريضه او سنه او يحرم الشيء او
يكره الشيء ثم ينسخ ذلك
ينسخ ينسخ حكمه
فالقبله
منسوخه وهذه حجه
دامغه لا يستطيع ردها
اي احد
لا يستطيع الذين ينكرون النسخ والفلاسفه
واهل الكلام لا يستطيعون ان ينكروا ان
اتجاه القبله
نسخت من بيت المقدس الى المسجد الحرام هذا
منسوخ ولذلك فان الله تعالى قصد هذا
بالنسخ يقول تعالى ما ننسخ من ايه او
ننسها ناتي بخير منها ومثلها الم تعلم ان
الله على كل شيء قدير
فالله عز وجل له ذلك ان شاء نسخ حكما
والنسخ يكون في الاحكام لا يكون في
الاخبار طبعا الخبر لا يقبل النسخ
لكن الاحكام
هذا يكون
محرما ثم يبيحه الله او شيء يكون مباحا ثم
يحرمه الله هذا كل نسخ نسخ الله سبحانه
وتعالى حكم الخمر نسخ القبله ونسخ بعض
بعض صفات في الصلاه
ونسخ بعض اللحوم حرمها بعد ان كانت مباحه
واوجب اشياء واشياء كانت محرمه
واحلها الله سبحانه وتعالى وهل هم جاره
فهذا النسخ يكون
ولم ينكر النسخ الا اليهود
فانهم يقولون لا يعقل ان ينزل الله تعالى
حكما ثم ينسخه لان هذا يقتضي
تكذيب الخبر يقتضي
تكذيب الحكم السابق وهذا الكلام باطل الله
عز وجل رد على هذا الكلام فقال ما ننسخ من
ايه او ننسها ناتي بخير منها ومثلها لم
تعلم ان الله على كل شيء قدير الم تعلم ان
الله له ملك السماوات والارض
له ان ينسخ الاحكام
بل بشكل عام من هذا القران
ناسخ للكتب السابقه اليس كذلك الم ينسخ
الله التوراه بالقران نعم
الم ينسخ
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صحف ابراهيم
بالتوراه مثلا
وكذلك الانجيل واختلف العلماء هل الانجيل
كان ناسخا للتوراه او كان ناسخا لبعض
التوراه
وعيسى عليه السلام ماذا قال لقومه قال
وليحل لكم بعض الذي حرم عليكم
فالنسخ متفق عليه بين العلماء بل كل
المسلمين اتفقوا على النسخ هذه مساله
قديمه
وشبهه قديمه لبعض الفلاسفه وبعض المتكلمين
سابقا انكر النسخ قال لا يمكن ان يكون
هناك نسخ
لكن الله سبحانه وتعالى اثبت الناسخ وهنا
في هذه الايه ما ننسخ من ايه او ننسها
يقولون لا هذا ليس هو النسخ الذي تقصدونه
ليس هذا رفع الحكم وابدال الحكم لا بل هذا
كيت وكيت وهذا الكلام كله غلط وباطي الله
عز وجل قد ينسخ الايه
بمعنى يبقي لفظ الايه وينسخ الحكم
وقد ينسخ الله سبحانه وتعالى
قد
قد ينسخ الله سبحانه وتعالى الحكم ويبقي
اللفظ قد ينسخ اللفظ ويبقي الحكم
وكذلك ينسخ سبحانه وتعالى القران بالقران
والسنه بالسنه اختلف العلماء
هل السنه تنسخ شيئا من القران
والجواب نعم يمكن لكن ما عنا مثال عليه
علماء رحمهم الله علماء الاصول ما وجدوا
مثالا
صحيحا صريحا في نسخ شيء من القران من
السنه لكنه بشكل عام هل يجوز يجوز لانه
كلاهما واحد من الله سبحانه وتعالى يمكن
ان ينسخ الله سبحانه وتعالى ايه في القران
بحديث
وكيف هذا
يعني مثلا
التخصيص
عمليه التخصيص
الله عز وجل ينزل ايه عامه
وتاتي السنه وتخصص هذا العام اليس هذا شبه
النسخ نفس الشيء
فالنسخ جائز
جائز ان ينسخ الله سبحانه وتعالى السنه
بالقران
وان ينسخ القران بالقران
ويجوز نسخ السنه بالقران عند بعض العلماء
لكن لا يوجد عليه مثال اصلا
الشافعي رحمه الله تعالى ذكر هذا واطنب في
ذكره في
كتابه
العظيم الشان
كتابه الرساله
ففي الرساله ذكر الناسخ وذكر امثله على
ذلك
وذكر الخلاف الذي وقع بين العلماء في هل
يجوز او يصح للسنه ان تنسخ القران
والشافعي رحمه الله قال لا القران ينسخ
السنه القران ينسخ القران لكن السنه لا
تنسخ القران وقد يكون قصده في ذلك
ان السنه لم ياتي مثال صحيح صريح في ان
السنه نسخت شيء من القران
لكن النسخ موجود في كل القران في كل السنه
موجود النسخ
والنسخ في لغه المتقدمين
يعني احنا ذكرنا مساله العموم الذي يخصص
يعني مثلا الله عز وجل يقول فاقطعوا
ايديهم فاقطعوا ايديهم
جزاء بما كسب نكال من الله هذا القطع يكون
لليد اليد في لغه العرب الى الى الكتف هنا
هذا كله يد
فاين القطع يكون
هنا او هنا او هنا جاء التخصيص صح ولا لا
في السنه
ان القطع يكون من الرخص من الرسخ هنا
ولا يجوز الزياده على ذلك الزياده على ذلك
ظلم
فهذا نسخ كيف هو هذا نسخ لان اليد احنا
اخرجنا كل هذا من المعنى وابقين هذا
فهذا يسمى نسخ جزئي وهو عند العلماء علماء
الاصول وسمى هذا التخصيص
لكن عند الصحابه ماذا كانوا يعبرون عن هذا
هذه العمليه التخصيص
كانوا يسمونه نسخا يقولون هذا منسوخ بكذا
يعني مخصص
لغه الفقهاء الاصوليين
استقرت لغتهم على ان الناسخ رفع حكم
واما التخصيص فله اسم اخر
لكن في زمن الصحابه والتابعين وتابعيهم
يقولون نسخ هذا منسوخ يعني هذا مخصص بهذا
فمثلا
في قول الله تعالى اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون حق تقاته
يعني التقوى التي يستحقها الله مين منا
يقدر على هاي
يقول ابن مسعود رضي الله عنه في هذه الايه
اتقوا الله حق تقاته ان يذكر فلا ينسى وان
يشكر فلا يكفر
وان يطاع فلا يعصى هذا هو تقوى الله حق
تقاتل في من واحد مطبقها هذه
هذا هو المعنى الاعم صح ولا لا
تقرا في كلام الصحابه
تجد ان ابن عباس رضي الله عنهما يقول هذه
الايه منسوخه
منسوخه بايش
لا يكلف الله نفسا الا وسعها
الان هو يقول منسوخه النسخ هنا في لغه ابن
عباس لغه الصحابه ليس معناه رفع الحكم
بالكامل
وابدال حكم بحكم بل معناه ايش التخصيص
يعني هذه الايه مخصصه بهاي كيف نفهم اتقوا
الله حق تقاته بنخصصها
فاتقوا الله ما استطعتم لا يكلف الله نفسا
الا وسعها هكذا هذه الايات فهذه الايه
عامه
لكنها خصصت
بايه اخرى هذه العمليه
يقال لها النسخ في لغه الصحابه
لذلك لما تقرا مثلا في كتب علوم القران
مثلا السيوطي رحمه الله ينقل في الاتقان
ان عدد الايات المنسوخه في القران ثمانين
اوف ثمانين ايه منسوخه في القران
هذا على لغه مين لغه الصحابه بمعنى 80 ايه
منسوخه بمعنى مخصصه
ياتي العموم وياتي تخصيصه هذا
هذه العمليه عمليه التخصيص هذه ايش هي في
الحقيقه نسخ لكن ليس نسخا لكل
الحكومه بل نسخ لايش لجزء من الحكم
فبيجي لك جماعه بقول لك لا النسخ مستحيل
في القران
واي ايه وحديث
توهم الانسان النسخ فليس معناه ما يظن
البنطلون هكذا يقولون
الله عز وجل ينسخ
الحكم
وينسخ اللفظ معا
يعني يكون في حكم ولفظ والله عز وجل ينسخ
هذه الايه لفظها ومعناها انسخها
تحاصل في القران
ويمكن ان ينسخ الحكم ويبقي اللفظ لفظ يبقى
والحكم منسوخ
وممكن وهذا واضح يعني في سوره الانفال
يقول تعالى الان خفف الله عنكم وعلم ان
فيكم ضعفا
فنسخ الحكم الذي قبله بايه
حكم الايه الاولى
الواحد بعشره
يعني اذا كان من المؤمنين عشره ويقابلون
ميه ما يجوز الفرار
بعدين نسخ الله سبحانه وتعالى هذه الايه
نسخ المعنى
واللفظ باقي
فجعل سبحانه وتعالى الواحد باثنين
اذا كان ميه من المؤمنين امامهم 200 لا
يجوز الفرار فوق الميتين يجوز
هذا نسخ واضح والله عز وجل حط ايه بعد ايه
وجاء ايضا
نسخ اللفظ
وابقاء الحكم مثل الرجم رجم الزاني المحصن
هذا متفق عليه بين الامه كلها مسلمين
بين علماء الاسلام وعلماء اهل السنه خاصه
فان الرجل معمول به
شهد اربع شهود عدول
وشاهدوا بما
ينبغي ان يشهدوا به فانه ماذا يكون الرجم
على المحصن
وهذا الذي قال عمر في صحيح البخاري انزلت
ايه الرجم فقراناها وعملنا بها ثم نسخ
اللفظ وبقي الحكم وراجم عمر وراجم رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فبيجيك بعض الجماعه ويقول شو هذا لا يمكن
سمعت واحد حتى
سالوه يعني وهذه الاسئله
تاتي في سوره
الشيء المستنكر
يعني معقوله يا مسلمين عندكم هذه القضيه
ولازم المسلم يلحق نفسه ويخبي اشياء من
دينه عشان الناس ما يعايروه
لا
ولا تاخذهم
بالله لومه تلائم هذا هو المعنى
كفار يلومون المسلمين على بعض احكامهم على
بعض دينهم
وهذا لا يؤاخذهم
لا تاخذهم في الله لومه لائم يصدعون بالحق
لكن بالحكمه
بسئل عن الرجم
فطلع يكون الرجم
هذا حكم يهودي
من شريعه اليهود
وهذا شيء
مستنكر في الاسلام
وهذه من شده اليهود وليس من شريعه محمد
شريعه السمحه وهذا كلام كلام باطل هذا
كلام باطل خالف الاجماع كله
ممكن الانسان يقول يا شيخ هذه كبيره يعني
الرجل نعم لكن ذا نظرنا في تاريخ الاسلام
كم حاله رجم حصل اشي قليل جدا
بجوز مره كل 100 سنه
لماذا
لان الناس يخافون من هذا الرادع
رادع عظيم
كذلك في بدايه الحكم كان الشيخ والشيخه
كما جاء في مسند احمد
وذكر بعضهم بان الايه كانت تقول
والشيخ والشيخه اذا زني فارجموهما البته
نكالا من الله
والله عزيز حكيم هكذا الايه كانت هذه
الروايه يصححها كثير من العلماء
المحدثين في مسند احمد
باسناد جيد
فبكل هذا في الشيخ والشيخه نعم لانه في
بدايه الامر
كان الحكم ايش الشيخ والشيخه يعني الكبير
في السن وصل سن الشيخوخه هذا يذهب
يعني هذا
يزني والعياذ بالله هذا مرض شديد يعني
تعدل اربعين سنه وهو لسه يمارس هذه
الاشياء
وبعدين لما استقر هذا الامر وعلم بفحشه
نسخ هذا اللفظ وبقي للمحصن
وهذا مثال يعني احنا هان في امريكا بدنا
نرجم حدا لا لكن مهم جدا انه المسلمين
يعرفوا دينهم
يجي جماعه يقولوا مستحيل الناسخ لا هذه
بدك تلوي كل القران عشان تزبطها هذه
فش نسخ القبله منسوخه كنا احنا متجهين
للبيت المقدس وصارت الى ايش الى المسجد
الحرام هذه هذا نسخ اذا هذا لم يكن نسخا
فما ادري ما الناس
هذا القول
جاء عن المعتزله هم الذين
جاءوا بهذا الفكر
واقتبسوه من بعض الفلاسفه
على كل حال هذه الشرور وهذه العقائد لم
تكن
معروفه للمسلمين الا بعد اول 100 سنه بعد
هيك صار المعتزله والجهميه وهذول الجماعه
يتكلموا في هذه الاشياء
وتسمع هذا الكلام
اليوم الناس
المتكلمون كثر في هذا الزمن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول في حديث
ابي هريره ومعاذ رضي الله عنهما
حديث في السنن
ياتي على الناس سنوات خداعات
يصدق فيها الكاذب ويكذب فيها الصادق
ويؤتمن فيها الخائن ويخون فيها الامين
وينطق فيه الرويبضه
قالوا ما الرويبضه يا رسول الله قال الرجل
التافه يتكلم في امر العامه
وفي بعض الاحاديث ان قبيل الساعه كثره
القراء وقله الفقهاء
وعن بعض الصحابه يكثر الخطباء ويقل
الفقهاء
الخطباء يعني الذين يقومون ويتكلمون
ويعلمون ويوجهون
هذولا يكثروا في اخر الزمان
بل جاء في صحيح البخاري
في كتاب تعبير الرؤى
عن جندب رضي الله عنه
ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
اخذه جبريل وميكائيل
ووقف هذا كان في الليل في المنام
ومنامات
الانبياء وحي
فمروا على رجل
مستلقاه
وقائم عليه رجل
معه كلاب
ويضع هذا الكلاب في شدقه
ويمزع حتى القفا
وفي منخره وفي عينه هكذا مزع هذا كله ثم
ينقلب الى الشق الاخر فما ينتهي من شق الا
والاخر تلائم وهكذا
وقيل هذا جزاؤه الى يوم الدين
فاخبره جبريل عليه السلام ان هذا كان يخرج
من بيته فيكذب الكذبه
تصل
زوايا الارض تصل اخر الارض هذه الكذبه ما
يروح عبيته في الليل الا وهالكذبه احاطت
بالارض
انا يعني ما استطيع اجزم مئه بالمئه انه
يتكلم عن زمننا هذا هذا من المتشابه لكن
هذا الزمن يعني
مناسب جدا لهذا العمل على كل حال
المقصود
انه الناس
بدال ما ياخذوا دينهم
من العلماء
بدل ما ياخذوا دينهم
في امكنه العلم
صار المكان اللي ياخذه منه دينهم
التلفاز
والراديو
وبعرف هذه قصه الراديو هذه راحت زمان يعني
لكن
التلفزيون
والواتساب والفيسبوك واللي مش عارف ايش كم
واحد بيجيني انا في الشهر بكل يا شيخ قرات
هذه على الفيسبوك هل هي صحيحه ضعيفه
اكثرها كذب واكثرها من كتب الرافضه
لكن هكذا الانترنت من اراد ان يقول قال في
اشي يمنع ابدا من مره
فبيطلع جماعات على الناس بطلعوا على على
النت
بطلعوا على الفضائيات والفضائيات هذه كانت
محنه عظيمه للمسلمين
لانه
القناه
بدها الناس تحضر صح
فهم مش بيجيبوا الواحد اللي بيتكلم بالخير
يجيبو وبيستضيفوا مين واحد بيوقف الشعر
حكيو يعني
واحد
ينكر البخاري واحد يقول عن نفسه مهدي واحد
يقول عن نفسه نبي وهيك يستضيفوا ليش عشان
الكل يتفرج على المجانين
فيستضيفون فلان الدكتور المهندس
هذا وكذا
ماذا يقول الدكتور
المهندس يقول ما في اشي اسمه نسخ في الدين
حلو وبعدين بيجيك الدكتور المهندس الثاني
ماذا يقول الدكتور المهندس الثاني
صحيح البخاري لا يعتمد عليه
وبعدين بيجيك الدكتور المهندس الفلاني
وايش بيقول الدكتور المهندس الفلاني
بقول لك ان الصلاه هي في الحقيقه ليست خمس
صلوات بل هي صلاه ركعتين عند الفجر
وركعتين عنده غروب الشمس
وسمو هذا علم يسمونه علم
وياتيك المهندس الفلاني والناس عشانهم
صاروا بعظموا الدنيا وبعظمه المال
صار الان اللي يدرس ويصير دكتور طبيب يعني
او بصير مثلا مهندس
فهذا من باب اولى بفهم القران لان الهندسه
صعبه والقران سهل اي واحد بيفهموا لكن
الهندسه هذه صعبه فما دام انه هذا اتقن
الهندسه فالقران هذه مثل شرب الماء فبيطلع
بالمهلكات بطلع بالويلات بان الناس والناس
بصدقوا
والله انا سمعت هيك وبيحفظ الناس بيحفظوا
كمان الادله
هؤلاء
هم دعاه على ابواب جهنم
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وصفهم
يتكلمون بلساننا وهم من بني جلدتنا
دعاء على ابواب جهنم من استجاب لهم قذفوه
فيه هيك
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اكبر في حديث
عبد الله بن عمرو في السنن
يصف زمن
حقيقه بزمننا ان
يقع في هذا الوصف يقول
اذا رايت الناس
مرجت عهودهم
وخفت اماناتهم
واعجاب كل ذي راي برايه
وكانوا هكذا
قال عبد الله رضي الله عنه عن ابيه ماذا
تامرني يعني في ذاك الزمان قال امسك عليك
لسانك
ما تزيد في الفتنه خلاص
امسك عليك لسانك
والزم بيتك
وخذ ما تعرف ودع ما تنكر
تعرف يعني اشياء انت بتعرفها من الاسلام
هذه معروفه معهوده
وداع ما تنكر اي شيء مشبوه جديد
شيء غريب يلفت النظر هذا اتركه بمعنى لا
تعمل به ولا تصدقه حتى تستفتي العلماء
خذ ما تعرف ودع ما تنكر وعليك بخاصه امر
نفسك ودع عنك امر العوام هكذا هكذا امر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وانا اطنبت في ذكر هذا هذه المساله مساله
الناسخ وكذا لاني اعرف
ان كثيرا من الناس
انجرف مع هذه الشبهات
ليش
وعشان الفضائيات وعشان الواتساب وعشان
فيسبوك من كان يظن من المسلمين
ان الفيسبوك
ينافس صحيح البخاري عند المسلمين من كان
يظن هذا الزمن ياتي يعني
موقع عليه الخلاعه او عليه الكذب وعليه
الكذا وكذا وكذا وهذا المكان هذا اصبح
المصدر الرئيسي لكثير من الناس حتى يتعرف
على كلام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
والله انا يعني
احلف بالله
في بيت الله
رايت احد هؤلاء
المتشدقين المتفقهين
طلع على القناه
ويقول صحيح البخاري هذا كتاب لا يعتمد
عليه ما المقصود من صحيح البخاري المقصود
الغض من القران هذا هو المقصود
لان صحيح البخاري هو اساس السنه اصبح
استقر راي العلماء عليه
اذا اذهبت البخاري
واصبح الناس يشكون في البخاري فما تحكي لي
لا مسلم ولا الترمذي ولا سنن بداود ولا
شيء كلهم تابع وعيال على البخاري
طلع ويقول هذا الكتاب البخاري لا يعتمد
عليه وانا اعطيك امثله وهو دكتور
مهندس
خرج من جامعه يعني مشهوره دينيه
طلع يقول اول شيء
البخاري
ليس هو صاحب كتاب صحيح البخاري
بخاري بدكم اعجب من هيك والله هذه يعجوبه
يعني الكتاب اسمه البخاري قال لك البخاري
الذي سمي عليه الكتاب
هذا واحد كان ضريرا عند الفرس
ولم يسافر ولم يجمع الحديث وين جاب القصه
هاي انا الى اليوم ما بعرف عاده الواحد
يستطيع يبحث ويلاقي اصل هذه الخرافات اقل
اشي تلاقي اصل له يعني
ما وجد
فطلع
عجيب
بخاري مقابل البخاري لا بس هو كان يتكلم
عن الجامع الصحيح المختصر الذي هو صحيح
البخاري
فماذا قال
قالوا اصلا مؤلف هذا الكتاب
اسمه مش البخاري
ايش اسمه يا دكتور
اسمه جمعه
هذا هذه تسميه ما كانت مشتهره في ذاك
القرن والذي يمارس الاسامي اسامي في
الاسانيد وكذا يعرف راسا جمعه مين هذا هذه
هذه تسميه يعني حادثه
فقال جمعه
محمد
مين جمعه محمد يا هل ترى
مكتوب على الغلاف شايف ورا الغلاف الغلاف
مكتوب عليه جمعه
جمعه يعني هذا الكتاب جمعه الزلمه مش عارف
بقول لك جمعه
وان شر البلاء ما يضحك
نشر البلاء ما يضحك واللي واللي
والماساه هذه استمرت كمان ساعتين ولسه في
بدايتها بيكون جمعه جمعه هذه اول ما ادلى
بدلوه قلنا ليته سكت
على كل حال الناس ما يعرفون
الله عز وجل يقول
منهم اميين لا يعلمون الكتاب الا اماني
وانهم الا يظنون
فالذي ياتي ويتكلم
باسم القران باسم السنه باسم العلم باسم
العلماء
ويقذف الناس في النار والعياذ بالله ويخرب
ويشوش على المسلمين دينهم في مفسد عظيمه
جدا
حاطت بهذا الزمن نسال الله العافيه
وتسبب من هذا قله احترام
وتقدير للعلماء الحق
علماء الحق
جماعه
اخلصوا في الطلب
ونذروا حياتهم
لهذا الدين
الحنيف الاغر
من اجل ان يدرسوه ويدرسوه ولكن كونوا
ربانيين بما كنتم
تعلمون الكتاب وبما كنتم تدرسون
نسال الله تعالى العافيه فعلى كل حال هذه
اشياء غريبه استنكرها الناس وحق لهم ان
يستنكروا لكن المشكله لما الناس بيقتنعوا
بهالكلام وبصيروا يجادلوا بالباطل
على كل حال النسخ امر مجمع عليه في الدين
في القران
الله عز وجل ذكر النسخ بلفظه وذكر النسخ
بمعناه في ايات عده من كتابه
ابرزها وعلى راسها ما ننسخ من ايه او
ننسها ناتي بخير منها ومثلها
سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء الله
الى غير ذلك
الله عز وجل وصف
الناس الذين
اعترضوا على نسخ
استقبال بيت المقدس فماذا قال
قال سبحانه وتعالى سيقول السفهاء من الناس
كلمه سفهاء جمع
والسفيه
في اللغه هو الذي لا يحسن التصرف
هذه يقال له
السفيه هو الذي لا يحسن التصرف ولا تؤتوا
السفهاء اموالكم صح ولا لا انه ما يحسن
التصرف
الله عز وجل يقول
ومن يرغب عمي التي ابراهيم الا من سفه
نفسه
الائمه ان يكون
اما ان يكون
بمعنى الانكار استفهام انكاري
واما ان يكون في معنى الخبر
بدلا من الانشاء
ومن يرغب عن مله ابراهيم الا من سفه نفسه
من ثاني بده يرغب عن هذه المله الا الذي
سفه نفسه يعني نفسه التي بين جنبيه لم
يحسن التصرف لها
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله
بقيت دقيقتين وكانت محنه من الله ليرى من
يتبع الرسول مما ينقلب على عقبيه ولما كان
شان القبله عظيما وطى سبحانه قبلها امر
النسخ وقدرته عليه
وانه ياتي بخير من المنسوخ او مثله ثم
عقبه بالتوبيخ لمن تعنت على رسوله ولم
ينقض له
ثم ذكر اختلاف اليهود والنصارى وشهاده
بعضهم على بعض بانهم ليسوا على شيء
وحذر عباده من موافقتهم واتباع اهوائهم
ثم ذكر كفرهم به وقولهم ان له ولد سبحانه
وتعالى
الى هذا القدر نكتافيه ان شاء الله بهذا
القدر
والى اللقاء
الاسبوع القادم والله اعلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم على نبينا محمد وجزاكم الله خيرا